dit is 1 replica
van het schip dat vroeger in de 17e 18e eeuw
de slaven verplaatste
van het ene continent naar het andere
als je dan weet hoeveel mensen men vervoerde
betekent het ook dat je je afvraagt
hoe hebben ze dat in godsnaam kunnen doen
John Leerdam
is 1 van de initiatiefnemers van het slavernij museum
dat in 2029 moet komen in Amsterdam
er zijn zoveel verhalen die mensen ons voorleggen
en die we in de research tegenkomen dat
het het wordt ingewikkeld genoeg
om alles in het museum te proppen
om inspiratie op te doen ging Leerdam naar musea
in andere landen
dit museum in Washington is onderdeel van het nationale
museum van de afrikaanse amerikaanse geschiedenis
het is 1 Groot succes
met meer dan 10 miljoen bezoekers
sinds de opening in 2016
voordat de succes op de museum
is that this is creative in a wave for everybody
because for you were
to see how this is
your story is where weather and see that i't instory
story or just the walk story
dit is de story of all who ban shape
by merkennosions of freedom
and marcino sense of hue whowe think we are
lonny bunge was onlangs even in Amsterdam
om zijn expertise
over het inrichten van 1 slavernijmuseum
te delen met de nederlanders
one of the biggest
where the netsons if you is just to story of savery
people will grac through one not engage
the great friend to this me username is
where do's all the stores what they slavery my gration
work sports
we verduste the human scare
so the people down begin the care the begin do in gates
so you got to make it person
wat je ziet in alle westerse landen
dat ze toch er altijd van uitgingen
dat zij waren de beste
de knapste
intelligenste
en de mensen met macht
en dat zien we nu zeker ook
na black lives matter
zien we daar 1 verschuiving in komen
het Kent het
het werd tijd